all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with invincible and
we're just going to get right into it
right so what this does is this
initially opens up with angstrom levy
this guy just won't go away man ancient
levy is he's the gift that keeps on
giving
the villain who keeps on returning but
ancient levy shows up here right now one
of the things to keep in mind angstrom
levy has kind of been on again off again
right in the sense that he's appeared
and he's disappeared and reappeared and
all that kind of stuff and for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with him or
at least who have forgotten about him
we'll do a bit of a refresher here in a
little while because one of the cool
things that kirkman does is he basically
reminds us of who angstrom levy is
because it's just been so long since
we've seen him but of course instead of
him having his monitors it allows him to
like see his orbs instead he could see
them directly right he can see like
directly through them and you know as
you would expect he's really kind of
celebrating here because invincibles is
arch nemesis and invincible's basically
dead but then when he picks up the
newspaper he finds out invincible's
death was faked and that he is actually
very much alive now what this does is
this kind of switches over to mark and
adam eve in the aftermath of adam eve
basically using her powers to create a
ring now one of the things that had
happened in the last story or the last
uh yeah last video that we didn't
necessarily cover because it was
something that would have made more
sense to cover here is that because of
the nature of adam eve's powers she's
very similar to the flash right those of
you guys who read the flash comics that
when it comes to like wally west or
barry allen or those guys they have a
sped up metabolism and so they have to
always keep it fed in order to make sure
that they don't you know right out of
energy or at least that's how it was in
the early days of wally west the
important thing here is that every time
adam eve uses her powers it basically
speeds up her digestive system and what
that means is that she essentially takes
nutrients away from her body and that's
what really kind of freaks her out a
little bit is because what she ends up
doing is of course her and mark go to
visit the doctor who initially told her
this in the first place and of course
we're out of even freaking out and
saying oh my god i use my powers you
know did i do anything to hurt my baby
the response to the doctor is no i mean
your baby's fine but basically it's
confirmed exactly what i thought right
like what you did here when you created
that ring is you basically performed or
you consumed as much energy as you would
consume if you had eaten like a whole
bunch of food right you basically robbed
your baby of sustenance had you kept
using your powers your body would have
basically gone through and just used
whatever energy it needed to and then it
would have eventually fed on your baby
i.e if you keep using your powers and if
you use your powers in the extreme your
body will literally consume your unborn
child right so what this does is it
provides a kind of handicap right in the
sense that adam eve just can't really
use her powers and as you guys know or
can imagine just by general
understanding of comic books this is
what we call a plot device
and it's actually handled pretty well by
robert kirkman and it's done pretty
interestingly but from there you
basically switch over to freddie mercury
right now remember nolan had defeated
freddie mercury and basically took
control of the villager might race now
it wasn't just him it was really the
other viltromites that seized control or
really kind of cast out freddie mercury
and placed nolan as their leader so it's
not enough for nolan to defeat freddie
mercury the rest of the vulture might
have to accept him as ruler which they
basically did and the general discussion
here is really more one that's tied down
to this idea of like we are basically
turning over a new leaf right the
various viltamites who are here on earth
some of them are just banging like
rabbits right so like just having all
kinds of kids some of them are like
settling down with families and so on
and so forth but whatever it is they're
essentially adopting exactly what we'd
hoped they would do which is basically
blend in with humanity right learn to
care learn to love that kind of a thing
right and so in reality the way it's
depicted here freddie mercury is kind of
the last holdout right like he's the
only vulture might that's holding on to
the old ways that vulture might use to
do things now there is a bit of a caveat
here in terms of the girl we'll talk
about that later but here's the thing
one of the little returns here that we
get and it's not overly important for
the sake of this story it'll be
important later on down the line the
mahler twins have returned really just
one of them uh the funny thing about
this is he just kind of comes out of
nowhere right like literally
invincible's like i thought you were
dead right and he's like i mean i'm a
genius right so like obviously i cloned
myself and then i've just been laying
low all this time i mean it's robert
kirkman kind of having a little fun just
sort of being like a hand wavy
explanation on why one of the mauler
twins is back but it is cool to see
right i don't know about you guys i
loved the mauler twins they were like my
favorite characters and invincible the
other funny thing about this is that
with adam eve not being able to use her
powers and not being able to fly she's
got to sit in traffic
[Laughter]
so she's kind of pissed off about having
to deal with traffic by and large it's
just little small things here and there
now the story actually begins to pick up
when she gets back home and she's met by
angstrom levy right an angstrom levy
immediately seizes control of her and
it's like okay so i wasn't expecting you
right i was expecting like debbie
grayson i was expecting you know like
like invincible's mom but you being here
is even better right and kind of starts
reading what's going on with her it's
kind of like okay so like obviously
you're terrified right you're kind of
kind of fearful of what's going on mark
does she does show up markets teleported
to a different dimension and of course
we'll follow up with that here in a
second but really the the conversation
with angstrom levy and adam eve is of
particular interest here and the reason
why is because ancient levy of course
while mark's basically in a different
dimension and he's like you know
eventually i'll bring mark back but
what's important here is he realizes she
can't use her powers right he's like
wait a minute he's like you're adam e
right he doesn't initially know it's her
right not right off the bat he was like
you're adam eve like okay like the
mighty adam eve right like you know uh
it's kind of interesting and all the
other dimensions you usually keep
yourself in pretty good shape but you
have a mighty waistline to go along with
your mighty powers and he's like you
could attack me but you didn't attack me
that's weird you're pregnant aren't you
right and that's where he kind of
figures out she can't use her powers
because if she does it'll basically kill
her kid now the way he knows this is
because of his observations of adam eve
across the entirety of the multiverse
and that's the cool thing here right
this is why this little segment is so
important because he says you know it's
kind of interesting looking at different
versions of invincible you and mark are
wildly intertwined throughout the
entirety of the multiverse right all
these different versions of mark out
there there's a lot of evil versions out
there right there are precious few
versions of mark that become a good guy
but the motivations for why mark becomes
evil are the most intriguing sometimes
it's because his father took him from
earth and raised him out in the
viltrumide empire and then they
eventually returned and conquered the
world sometimes it was because of some
other circumstance right he was just oh
just a dick as a kid and just never
stopped being a dick and then ultimately
grew into a villain he's like but more
often than not what ends up happening is
that in that reality you die and when
that happens mark snaps and then he
basically just ends up becoming a bad
guy it's always that way like almost
every single time that always ends up
happening in fact he actually comments
on one circumstance and saying like
there was one particular universe where
the lizard league was a lot more
dangerous there than they were here and
they came after you and mark and it was
only really one one of two circumstances
that could be chosen either you could
fight them without your powers or you
could use your powers and kill your
unborn baby and you were so confident
that you could defeat them without your
powers that you died and it took your
unborn baby with them and then mark
snapped right mark lost it and so that's
kind of the funny thing is he's like
you're safe you know until mark gets
back because mark is the person that i'm
after but that's that's a hugely
insightful thing because up to that
point all we really saw in terms of like
alternate reality depictions of mark and
adam eve is that there was just some
future version of adam eve where mark
never said anything about his interest
in her and she was never able to let
mark go and so because neither of them
ever really communicated because she
just never told him how she felt uh
ultimately she just ended up growing up
to be miserable and that version of adam
eve of course warned mark about that and
that's what set mark on the path of
telling adam eve in its present time hey
like i dig you girl let's see if we
can't uh turn that frown upside down you
know what i mean like making his move
putting his moves on the girl and so
it's one of those those funny little
things because switching over to this
dimension where mark is teleported to
ironically enough it's the dimension
where all the other versions of
invincible were teleported to right if
you guys remember the invincible war at
the conclusion of that story all those
alternate reality versions of mark were
all just kind of sent to this sort of
wasteland where basically everything had
fallen apart when mark gets there he
ends up finding out that seemingly all
but one of them survived and basically
they all ended up turning to cannibalism
right to essentially consume each other
the the one of them who was the biggest
dick he was the one that was killed
first but then they all basically just
started eating each other now of course
in this fight that breaks out between
mark and this alternate reality version
of himself then ultimately mark is saved
by a second version right so there's
basically a second survivor here who
ends up whisking mark away and says like
we have to get out of here right like it
doesn't matter who you are it's
irrelevant he's going to kill you and
he's going to eat you right the only way
i survive is just by basically hiding
staying hidden in these different places
and trying not to get caught up in
different things now at that point we
switch back to adam eve this is a really
really cool thing when adam eve has this
conversation with angstrom levy one of
the things to remember is angstrom levy
doesn't fully understand himself right
that's what was established in the
initial story arc with angstrom levy
that his whole mechanism and scheme is
that he was a guy who wanted to
basically absorb all the knowledge of
his alternate reality counterparts and
then use that as a means to basically
make the world a better place but also
kind of make himself rich at the same
time right so he wasn't really looking
at world domination it was like i mean
we're gonna make the world better for
everybody else and we're gonna make it a
little bit better for me but like we're
gonna make it better for everybody else
right which in all honesty which of you
would say no to that right like if i
told you you could make the world better
for everybody and will make you a
billionaire in the process i would not
believe you if you told me you would say
no to that right no no no that's not the
right thing to do we need to make sure
everybody has a billion no i wouldn't
believe you for a second right like you
know you justify it
but one of the funny things is that in
that battle that had taken place right
like when when essentially mark had
shown up that ancient levy had summoned
like all these different versions of the
mauler twins from across the multiverse
and a great big huge calamity took place
but realizing basically the error of his
ways angstrom levy pulled himself out of
the machine and in doing so caused a
great big huge explosion and basically
scrambled himself right like scrambled
his own memories so what he has going on
up there in his old noggin is really a
combination of memories from different
versions of himself so he doesn't really
remember things as they actually
unfolded instead he just remembers
things based on how he believes they
unfold it's kind of interesting right
it's like nostalgia just because we
remember things being a certain way
doesn't mean they were that way that's
just how we remember them being right
that we as people our memories are not
really reliable right i mean it doesn't
really work that way right we have a
tendency to kind of skew how it is that
we recall things and so adam eve calls
it out on it calls him out on that right
she's like i mean look here's the thing
you need to know what you recall it's
nothing like what happened right like
you literally did this to yourself so
here's the question while you're like
running around being pissed off and
chasing after mark one of the things
that i've learned in this life is there
have been ample times where i could seek
out revenge but i've chosen not to i'm
just gonna live my life right like
either you can live your life consumed
by anger and basically going nowhere
right you'll ultimately end up one step
ahead of where you are right now or you
can move on right like you can be a
redditor and just be pissed off at the
world or you can be a person who gets
their life together and actually fixes
their life right which one do you want
to be and so it's one of those
interesting things where ultimately
she's like imagine what you could do
with this world if you were a person who
actually did something with your life
who took all this knowledge that you
have all this this gigantic skill set
and this drive and desire to kill mark
and channeled it into something
productive imagine what you could
achieve you know he's kind of like i
mean i guess i mean i could be a
redditor and just blame the world for my
problems or i could be somebody who
could actually fix my life right and so
it's really him just kind of turning
over a new leaf and becoming somebody
better right which is kind of
interesting that it was adam eve who was
the one that was able to get him to do
that now following that of course
switching over to this alternate
dimension basically this you know this
mohawk mark is we're gonna call we're
gonna call him mohawk mark uh he
basically ends up beating to death the
the cannibal mark right and so it's just
him and invincible that's basically it
at that point ancient levy opens a
portal that normal mark right good mark
basically basically flies through it and
then when he shows up there his initial
response of course is to attack angstrom
levy but before he could do anything
mohawk mark comes racing in and then
immediately starts pummeling the guy now
of course good mark basically offers
some measure of a distraction which
allows angstrom levy to get the get the
upper hand for a brief moment and then
anxious he's like everybody stop right
like here's the thing right i've had
this conversation with with adam eve and
basically my wires were crossed right
like i was absolutely convinced that
mark was the villain here when in
reality my memories were all screwed up
right i didn't remember things the way
they actually were i remember them the
way that i wanted to remember them right
like i was choosing my own reality as
opposed to looking at the reality for
what it is and so ultimately where he's
trying to kind of become a good guy and
it's like look i mean at this point i
surrender right like i give up like i
will serve my sentence to society and
then assuming that i attain some measure
of freedom at a future point in time
hopefully i can just like use my
intelligence to basically make the world
a better place and then of course he
opens the portal so mohawk mark can go
back to his own dimension and the
response to mohawk mark is like you know
what we have a way to fix guys like this
and just grabs angstrom levy and flies
through the portal and that's it right
like the portal just shuts right now
it's kind of one of those funny things
is because at the end of the day mark
has this desire to find angstrom levy
and we don't really know entirely why we
simply just know that he does right
maybe it's because extra levy can prove
himself and become somebody who's
productive right imagine what he could
be if he was a force for good and so
mark ends up approaching uh rex right
rex robot and it's just kind of like i
need you to basically create a portal
that will allow me to find angstrom levy
right to access him and then basically
find a way to bring him in right to
essentially find a way to to bring this
guy back so we could do something with
him now there is a bit of an important
thing that also goes on here and i do
want to discuss this it's the fate of
freddie mercury right so switching back
over to uh to nolan where he's talking
with like the rest of the villager mites
and then basically talking to uh talking
to freddie mercury the funny thing is
that freddie mercury had constantly told
him you should kill me right not because
i'm gonna like kill you myself i mean he
would if he seemingly if he got an
opportunity to but his response is like
what you're doing here is cute and it's
it's nice and everything but the reality
is that viltrumides will not follow
weakness all that's going to happen here
it could be a century right it could be
even longer than that it could be less
time than that something will happen and
this weakness that you have will come to
bear and the viltrumites will hate you
for it and they will come back to me
they will kill you and they will come
back to me and i will be their leader
now the whole response of of no at that
point in time is no right things are
different now like they are making a
better life for themselves i have a
better life for myself you're the last
holdout and so here basically at this
point where freddie mercury is being
sentenced that nolan does not really
sentence him to death right he's just
kind of like
we're literally just going to sentence
you to life your fate is to basically
watch your people grow beyond you to
become better than you and so he
actually ends up freeing him and is like
your sentence is to be exiled right find
some dark corner of the universe away
from the coalition of worlds away from
earth or something like that and live
out the rest of your days right stay
away if you come back we will kill you
if you go to the coalition of worlds
they will kill you because i will tell
them that you have been exiled right
like you have no allies out here in the
universe there's no one here who's
watching you no one keeping an eye on
you or anything like that you're on your
own right so if you screw up bad enough
everybody will kill you and so it's kind
of a crazy thing here is because from
that point what you end up doing is
basically switching over to the return
of battle beast and i know a lot of you
guys loved battle beasts right a lot of
you guys absolutely loved this guy and
it makes sense battle beats was pretty
legit right this guy was pretty hardcore
he's certainly just a fan favorite right
the guys just like died in the wool
conflict right just fighting and all
that kind of stuff the funny thing is
that he's actually freeing a world uh
under the protection of the coalition of
worlds from like an imposing threat
right from from some other threat out
there i mean we don't really get to see
the full extent of the battle we just
kind of pick up with battle beasts just
destroying these guys and it's just kind
of crazy and so one of the things that
goes on is that with him basically being
saved of course or at least saving this
world he's basically approached by uh by
a member of the coalition who's like
look like alan the alien wants you right
he needs you to come back and so like
this super hot alien chick is like you
saved our world battle beast right you
know we we can never truly repay you for
for everything you've done but i'm
pretty sure i can repay you about
wow and she's like take me away from
here and he's like okay so like we all
know that battle beast is like yeah
so it's it's one of those cool little
moments right nothing too major here
right nothing huge but it's a cool
little moment with regard you know with
regards to the return of uh of battle
beast and so one of the things that goes
on is that out of the alien the reason
why battle beast has been brought back
here is because where he shows up to
alan alien he's like look i mean there's
no glory here there's no battle here
like surely you're not calling me back
here for nothing and the response of
alan is no we're not calling you back
for nothing we're calling you back for
something right former grand regent
freddie mercury of the viltrum empire
has been exiled right this guy no matter
what omniman nolan believes this guy is
a credible threat to the universe so i
want you to find him right to hunt him
down and i want you to kill him i want
you to kill grand admiral thrack at that
point you switch back over to uh to to
monster girl and monster girl basically
goes to visit her son now again for
those of you guys who are a little
baffled as to why it is that she you
know why her son refers to her as father
this again ties into the really the kind
of history of monster girl and uh and
rex that we had covered in a previous
video right that one of the things that
had happened is that if you guys recall
the flaccid race those guys had
constantly invaded earth like we've seen
it happen multiple times and they were
doing it for the purpose of like
basically taking over the world and then
using earth's resources right humanity
as a labor force different things like
that and so monster girl and rex had
basically entered the portal and then
essentially conquered the entirety of
the uh of the the flax in the race and
then in turn things got pretty bleak
right that rex had basically pushed
monster girl away due to a series of
different things that had happened right
like emotionally pushed her away she
turned into the actual monster version
of herself and then ran off with another
alien basically banged and then that's
where some came from right now the the
sun ultimately ended up leading an
invasion of of the the flaccid race onto
earth and of course was ultimately
defeated and now is being kept prisoner
the funny thing is that uh that monster
girl had no idea that rex had actually
ordered her son to be hunted down and to
be executed right to be killed along
with the with any other members of the
flagship royal family right she didn't
know that robot had done that and so
because of that when she's told by her
son i was being hunted down all the time
because of like robot monster girl
denies it she's like no there's no way
that's true right like there's no way
he'd be capable of something like that
you're just here be you're just saying
this because you're angry and you just
want to lash out and like you want to
hurt us and you want to hurt him and so
the response of her son is okay who are
we talking about here the man who
conquered the flacks of the world
enslaved the zaxel royals and then ruled
my home with an iron fist who drove you
to rebel drove you into my mother's arms
and then you in turn helped to overthrow
him or this innocent man that you've
fallen in love with all over again right
love conquers all like that kind of a
thing and like obviously the proof is in
the pudding right and so again that's
where she's like no like none of that's
true this conversation is over and then
just basically least but the seeds have
been planted right that little thought
that little nugget right that seed in
the back of her head is gonna grow it's
just gonna consistently grow over and
over and over again and it isn't really
gonna go anywhere and so what ends up
happening here is that where you end up
having you know kind of picking back up
with the the grayson home that mark is
met with uh really with a call from
robot who's like i've managed to find a
way to work this portal right i've
basically finally managed to find a way
to get us to where angstrom levy's going
to be to this alternate universe and
mark goes on the mission with him now of
course adam eve's pissed off about it
right she's like i mean it's time to let
this go right let langstrom levy go like
whatever he's gonna be stuck there
forever who cares right at the end of
the day mark's like no like i need to i
need to know that like you're protected
our baby's protected i need to know that
like you guys are safe right like i need
to know what's going on because in
reality mark will always kind of see
angstrom levy as a threat until the
actions of angstrom levy prove that he's
a good guy mark always sees him as a guy
that'll come back right that anxious
levy's in some alternate reality and
maybe because of everything that's going
on he'll come back blaming mark and be
like we have to attack again right so
keeping his family safe it just makes
good sense and so once this portal is
open by rex and by by mark and they pass
through they get back on this world
they're of course met by this world's
arrival of basically conquest and that's
kind of the crazy thing because remember
conquest was a villager might that
basically market kill right it took him
a little while to do it but he had
basically defeated this guy right killed
this guy but one of the things to keep
in mind that mohawk mark comes from a
world where the viltromites had
conquered earth right where earth had
basically been taken over by the
villager might race and like that was
basically it and so once they all bring
uh really bring mark and and robot
directly to mohawk mark that they're
kind of like okay this guy seems like a
credible threat or both of these guys do
mohawk markers like no no they're cool
right these guys are cool like
everything everything is awesome right
like this guy you know he basically
saved me and everything's copacetic
right don't worry about it you guys go
about do your own thing right and
everything's everything's cool and so
mark's like okay so what's going on with
angstrom levy right like what's going on
with this guy and so what had happened
here is that when angstrom levy had
originally contacted these alternate
reality versions of mark specifically
this guy that ancient levy had made the
promise that if they were to defeat
invincible or destroy that world where
they had been brought to right the main
invincible universe that angstrom levy
would help them expand their empires
into other dimensions right so they
would rule entire universes but when
angstrom levy was brought here right in
this this particular video that he
refused to do the same thing right
because he had found some newfound
responsibility or something like that
and so ultimately he's basically been
taken by the scientists under the
control of the velcromites he's being
dissected i mean this guy is basically
being tortured right he's being kept
alive but i wouldn't say this is any
measure of survival at all the guy is
basically just better off dead right but
they're trying to access the information
inside of his mind and use the the you
know that knowledge to their own ends
and so that's what's so crazy is because
this version of mark is basically
displaying a kind of ruthlessness just
callous ruthlessness whatever it takes
to get you know to get what he needs and
robot is basically watching all of this
now the other thing about this and
really the most damning thing is that
mohawk mark basically says you know like
we all talk to each other like when we
were locked in that dimension we all
talked to each other you know before we
started eating each other anyway we
talked about what it is that turned us
and one of the things that we learned is
that there were so few of us that
actually ended up being good guys that
you basically seemed like one of the
very few versions of us from across the
multiverse that basically became a hero
and so what ends up happening is robot
actually activates this kind of device
that basically exists in the minds of
seemingly all of them right basically
disrupts their inner ear function in the
same way that dinosaurus did the reason
why robot does this of course he
basically kills all the scientists and
then he shoots a bomb into the brain or
at least into the mouth of mohawk mark
and then basically destroys him from the
inside out and the reason why he does
this when mark asked him like why are
you doing this he's like hold on like i
need to take care of something first and
then he kills angstrom levy right like
literally it's a bloodbath he kills like
everybody here and that good mark is
basically the only one left alive and
robot says after being here and after
seeing what you could potentially become
the reality is that you're too much of a
threat but more so than that what rex
seems to be doing is working behind the
scenes to essentially conquer the world
right he's like i'm going to conquer
this place and i'm going to bring peace
to the world whether it wants it or not
seeing what you become seeing what
you're capable of the kind of
ruthlessness it's not that i'm concerned
about you killing humanity or anything
like that i'm concerned that you would
overpower me and in reality because of
the nature of my plans and what i'm
shooting for here there could only be
one person who rules the world right
there can only be one person who does
this so one thing to understand is that
everything that's gone on here is
basically limited to this particular
space this room nobody outside this room
knows what happened here but they will
find out and so regardless of what it is
that you end up doing you better think
fast because people are gonna come into
this room and then from where they're
sitting it's gonna look like you killed
mohawk mark and the rest of the
scientists you're gonna look like you're
the guy who came out on top right who
literally assassinated the leader of the
vulture might race as it exists on earth
they will kill you so find something do
something but you better hurry with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i don't mean to leave you guys on a
cliffhanger but it's literally how the
story ends i feel like cliffhanger is
like a hallmark of the invincible videos
at this point in time like like it was
funny reading your own comments from the
last video you're like okay i didn't
need any of my uh of my cliffhanging
gear right there's no there's no
cliffhangers here well now you have one
anyway i will catch you all later peace